wisst ihr was die public opas können es
einfach immer noch wir sind zwar alt und
hier sind gebrechlich aber in den
knochen
und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge monologe spielen teamcamp liegt
mit dem bei nbb dem wissel auf die top 3
anbieter gefallen haben aber fly nicht
zu oft runter so schlecht für deine
gesundheit
je mehr mühe du kriegst rückenschmerz
männer das dorf macht ja und wir
versuchen heute einfach mal ist also
hört eigentlich versuche einfach
schwierig zu spielen
das ist ein bisschen ist ein bisschen
spät sagen weil man ja wobei es geht
noch alter ist es noch eine relativ
normale zeit als wenn es gerade für
fragen der prosieben dafür sehen wir was
ist das schön wärs wenn wir 25
und es ist freitag ist etwas video einem
samstag eigentlich wollte ich noch mal
rausgehen und feiern es wird
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen spätere
nummer war ich auch die bude putzen muss
ich mich noch klamotten waschen balla
balla balla balla aber eventuell werde
ich nachher nochmal raus gehen in den
tresor club hier in berlin gut bei der
abend plan nicht matrix nicht warten
dieser matrix voll der touri schuppen ja
sicherlich
der ist vielsagend ich kann das ja auch
noch regen ja der ist voll verschrieben
als tourist und alle inhalte in wegen
berlin tag gemacht ja glaube ich ja doch
genau so ist es ja was machst du heute
abend nachdem was ich geplant noch ein
video zu machen können und relativ früh
raus dann finden in wien bei studios
avanti worden die machen nämlich hier
action action bootcamp zeug so weiter
ach was schaust du ja dass er frei oder
frau eigentlich vorher was soll ich
sagen vor zwei jahren hätte ich mich für
diesen lebensrhythmus einfach korrekt so
einfach freitag arbeiten am pc zu sitzen
nichts zu machen
ich muss echt mal rausgehen leute
jeweils fünf wochen in berlin war
einfach kein einziges mal feiern
ja ich jetzt alle liebevoll die party
statt ja aber ich habe einfach keine
power
ich bin so froh als ich war so froh gut
diese woche bist ein chilliger bisschen
urlaub hatte aber ich war so froh wenn
der freitag haben und ich endlich mal
ausschlafen konnte dass ich halt 0
motiviert war irgendwie feiern zu gehen
als einmal ganz kurz hast du diesen part
mit diesen mit den teppichen und den
zahlen schon gemacht diesen blockbuster
da ist keiner glaube ich oder ich nicht
gibt es gibt kisten ich weiß ich hab
mich gerade darauf hin dass sie aber die
kiste wieder vergessen habe ich gefunden
ich laufe einfach durch stimmt das recht
hier glaub ich ist übersehen
sieht man da noch irgendwas da hab ich
nicht gesehen ich habe auch geguckt
jetzt noch ich habe jeden block mit der
anders aber keine ahnung was machen dann
ist ja gut gewesen habe mit abstand
wieder mal die die oberste lage obwohl
die jump community sich richtig krass
entwickelt hat das ist ja aber ich
mitbekommen ich weiß nicht was passiert
das wurde jetzt nicht auf einmal populär
also das ist es nicht oder es ist
einfach glaube ich war weil man
dieselben sachen immer wieder springt
die leute haben sich halt ja klar und
das ziel so viele neue pass zu bekommen
und wir spielen nicht besorgt wir uns
heraus gekommen ist ein anfang aber
dementsprechend selten
und deswegen sind wir halt
dementsprechend wahrscheinlich schlecht
also die meisten leute deshalb häufiger
zocken diese stammte von dem server weil
dir einfach jeden partnern auch schon
kennen auch mit einmal raus kommt man
will also die jump league opa ist
richtig so wir sehen sowie die ganzen
unsere enkel jetzt an uns vorbeiziehen
einfach viel besser sind
so wie unsere opas ich denke das ist ein
handy das letzte was ich dieses modul
wir verpacken einfach mit der rolle habe
ich ganz offen das kann ich auch
was hatte ich verwirrt dass mit der
rolle frühere alles ohne wie es früher
war alles besser
2000 jahre später das ist nicht wahr was
wir sehen ein sieger der leben liebe
leute
das ist einfach nicht wahr es gibt nicht
wie lange ich in diesem modul hänge ja
ja danke schön euer haus geschafft jetzt
ja ich hab jetzt modulen eigentlich
geschafft dass er nicht bleibt hier
hängen noch schilder so eine ohrfeige
okay jetzt setzte ich könnte das
tatsächlich mal finde schon leute dann
habe ich das jetzt mit einem video
befindet
ok ich kann mich noch erinnern damals er
sich eine runde mit 0 am place gemacht
hast das habe ich bisher noch nie
geschafft hat noch nie die runde mit ich
hab auch in dem stream habe ich schon
mal im stream heute folgt die champions
aus gekommen ist habe ich gleich einen
stream geschafft habe ich drei tage
später dreimal nur einen stempel nicht
ich glaube ich glaube es war sogar nur
ein paar tage davor habe ich eine runde
aufgenommen hatte gar keinen drang auf
youtube immer noch braucht ich hab das
muss ich mal schauen
das macht mir mal nach meiner
eigentlichen er ohne wird eine
schlamperei ja wir sind wir sind ja
schon ein bisschen in die jahre gekommen
oder es immer noch drauf und sagt okay
gibt
ich musste leider durch sprint und finde
schon was hätte ich den sprung niemals
geschafft man ja jetzt rächt sich
einfach dass ich kein urlaub buchen
jetzt noch klar
eigentlich haben wir bald eine links der
ems da habe ich auch noch nicht okay
dann machen wir es mal unser eigenes
ding
ich bin hier zu einer der hat die ganze
welt glaube ich sehe ich aber nicht mit
mir mein freund ok erster und fashion
designers vielen armen leute leute leute
leute leute
wisst ihr was die public opas können es
einfach immer noch wir sind zwar alt und
gebrechlich aber jetzt aber drauf den
knochen
es ist einfach die erfahrung der privat
ist halt dass du hast einfach so ein
pigment skin picking es genau du gibst
du erstmal auf die backen und ich guck
mal hier was drin ist das nichts drin
wie hier die party abgeht aber ja hier
alles da ist das thema passen das war
nicht okay läuft gar nicht aufisst über
leute richtige party
die runde weil ich richtig schnell man
wir mitnehmen jetzt gerade über acht
minuten auf und es hagelt einfach kills
in diesem match also früher wie ich
klein war liegt jeder angefangen hat zu
spielen
jugend 150 jahren erzählte daran hier
daran die weniger leute ohne willst
mittlerweile ist etwa alles überfüllt
ja es ist richtig krass aber was soll
man machen wenn man muss er wieder mit
klarkommen irgendwie industrielle
revolution ja genau die industrielle der
virtuelle debatte ich hole mir den
demokraten erfolg dass das eine
sackgasse
ok es dauern die anderen kommen wo ich
geh einfach mal lauter schießt mit
pfeilen worden und das ist aber nicht
wahr
man las weniger der deshalb geständnis
ab - daran kann ich da nicht gegangen
aber ich dachte ich natürlich auch
wirklich wieder 20.000 ist vergessen
habe kannst schaffen
ja aber noch um hilfe geben aber dass
dieses geld abhängig wie das böse nicht
so gut wie alles da was man auch weiß
was ich mache
ich nehme dich bremer kurz stehen ja
okay ich hab mich anruft jetzt habe ich
einen wieder sein der da legst du dir
erklären sie schon gesammelt und jetzt
wir haben beide noch drei leben was für
einen rekord in killzone ja ich hab's
geschafft man alle leute zu töten
also alleine etwas 24 habe ich auch auf
youtube an diesen übrigens hat beide
werden den bauern je 1 21 us-dollar so
schnell darauf kann ich mal machen
werden screen spielen konventionen des
spielen können auf ihn gehen wir
ich glaube ich hab mich gekillt
herr leute die 100 was sie sprechen auch
sie ab diesen locker wie das verpacken
du hast mein leben 21 naja ich denke ein
bisschen auf den gehen wir welchen
abständen auf dem mit gold okay
das ist aber auch eine kiste
ich kann mich berichten was in der
kisten klebt oder fest
die zwei leben egal
das war nicht okay okay ziemlich runter
nein nein nein das will ich nicht
österreich verfehlt scheinbar ist der
bessere oper ein dicker stein motorrad
und jack w
also leute wir haben gesehen ich bin der
oper der besser laufen kann wenigsten
oper der besser kämpft
das war ich doch sagen und jetzt schön
samstag